hi i'm ria i'm a tasty producer today
i've been challenged to take a common
food and
make it fancy the rules are you must use
the food given
you can only add to the food you can buy
whatever ingredients you wish
once you begin cooking you must complete
upgraded dish in 30 minutes
let's see what it is this time
marshmallows i have had a marshmallow
before
this is very unusual for this show
yeah it's marshmallows
it's a little too sweet for me it's
very fun i love touching
marshmallow i wish it was my pillow
i wish i'll be making big for me
texture is kind of boring you don't want
to eat it as it is
sometimes like you make s'mores
sometimes you
put in a hot chocolate can i make
something to
express my feeling about marshmallow
marshmallows a
blank canvas right i'm super excited i
got some great ideas
i cannot wait to
make it fancy here is what i got
chocolate 100 cocoa fresh raspberries
heavy cream coconuts vanilla ice cream
from the pantry i got edible glitter
and rum i also have two secret weapons
for this time
this is my girl little
spoon princess and edible gold from my
private collection
alright let's get started
make it fancy alright let's start the
clock
30 minutes starts
now i'm going to use same amount of
marshmallows
and same amount of heavy cream so i'm
using 100 milliliter
i'm going to put in a pot
and melt them
marshmallow is very sweet so it has a
lot of sugar in it
if you heat it up too hard it's going to
bung on the bottom
meanwhile i'm going to chop chocolate
100
cacao so it's not sweet at all
if you just want to eat it yeah you
don't want to eat it
by itself so since marshmallow is super
super
sweet i didn't want to add any sugar
even bitter sweet chocolate i feel like
it's gonna be a little bit
too sweet i'm just chopping very finely
so it will melt quickly
[Music]
so i put 115 gram chocolate
that's my taste that's a bad idea
i knew it but i just couldn't help okay
let's check the timer i have almost like
27 minutes left
marshmallow is melting i'm gonna just
melt
completely
alligator it's like 90
melted the texture is almost like an
evaporated milk it's a little bit
thicker than heavy cream
it's a little bit looser than condensed
milk just make sure everything is melted
no like white beets from marshmallow and
i'm going to add chocolate in a bigger
bowl
so i'm going to just pour over chop the
chocolate
i have about 24 minutes left i'm going
to mix with
whisk you just wanted to make sure
everything
is well incorporated texture-wise
kind of look like mayonnaise kind of
thick
like that
yeah it's much better i have
ice baths and i'm going to
whip some cream i'm not sure how much
heavy cream i have to whip
so i'm gonna just start with one cup i'm
using
ice baths because when heavy cream is
colder it weeps
faster so i want to use whisk instead of
hand mixer because i can control the
texture i want
oh i thought something rum
hey i'm gonna start with half
tablespoon wow
it's heavy half tablespoon of
rum so far i feel like i'm using
booze for my cooking
i'm just like whisking and kind of
switching my wrist because it's like
hard work
when my wrist is tired i kind of like
change the direction i'm going there's
no
right or wrong way just whip all of my
arm muscles are coming from whisking
whipped cream
so it's almost ready i want to
do a soft peak so now i'm going to
combine
these two nice and oily
i'm gonna add a little bit oh nice
i like the color so let's get everything
nice
[Music]
i think it need a little bit more rum
you don't need to add rum at all if you
don't like alcohol
if you're underage but
i'm adult i do what i want
[Music]
it's so good so i'm going to transfer
this to
piping bag i'm using a star tip
you don't need to use it i just using it
to make it fancy
let's check the timer 12 30. so i'm
going to
rest this in the refrigerator be right
back for my next step
i'm going to use more marshmallows and
make something totally different
i'm gonna just use four of them
so i'm going to put this in a microwave
for just 15 seconds
and i'll be right back
i microwave marshmallows and it's soft
and nice i'm going to
put in a baking sheet oh it's very
sticky yeah
i'm spreading it so i don't need to cook
too long basically i'm making this
marshmallow
into crispy cookies so i'm going to bake
this
in the oven my marshmallow cookie is
baking in the oven
and i'm going to pipe this mixture into
champagne glasses because champagne
glass is fancy
so i'm using star tip and it kind of
makes
beautiful like rose kind of shape and i
want to
fill all the way up to the limb
this is really pretty so i don't want to
mess with that i like using coconuts
because it's
bitter so if you're making something
super sweet
it will balance out the flavor
and also it has a nice crunch cookie
should be done so i'm gonna grab it
all right it's nice and brown it's
crispy
i just want to give a little you know
glitter for
a cute presentation let's check the
timer
about four minutes left so i got ice
cream and hot water
i like using this pen because it's nice
carb and pointy tip when you go to fancy
restaurant there is a
football shaped ice cream this kind of
spoon
works the best ice cream is super cold
and it's hot water so it melts it's been
a while so don't judge me
you just need practice it's not the easy
thing you can do from the first time
let's check the timer and i have two
minutes left
final stretch and i just top with
raspberry
my other secret weapon edible gold
so you don't want to use a lot the
cookie
[Music]
it's nice and crisp can you hear the
cracking sound
i'm gonna just place it like that
and we're done
[Music]
so good it's maybe the fanciest i made
right hannah welcome to fancy lounge
it's beautiful i want to live here yeah
we have all kinds of different
hardly car that's all you need
you need hard liquor and some dessert
all right do you want to try
yes i feel like if i was out of fancy
tea this would be the grand finale
it's so beautiful did you hear that i
mean there's gold on
oh my god
oh my god i'm gonna dip you
[Music]
i would never in my life guess that this
is made out of a marshmallow
yes did i make fancy this is the
fanciest thing i've ever
used make it fancy ryan
welcome to my marshmallow one dollar
marshmallow
wonderland i made a chocolate mousse and
a cookie from marshmallow
wow and the raspberry raspberry is not
much much
wow big ol one clump of goldfish
this is my private collection this is
your pride you have a private collection
of gold flakes i also have a collection
of flakes
what's kind of flake
[Music]
has anybody done this has anybody
actually hannah did but you can do it ah
no
i like to be original
it's quite good thank you should we do
the dance
of course okay this one yeah this way
first
yes okay three two one make it fancy
thank you for watching i hope you will
make marshmallow fancy
if you do please tag me on instagram
hashtag make it fancy
and don't forget to dance make it fancy
[Music]